with it being halloween time i thought
it'd be a great time to check out some
more of markiplier this time we're gonna
watch a horror reaction compilation from
the man
who people say i look like and i say he
is my
better looking better voiced more
successful
distant cousin that's how i answered
that but before we hop
into this i do want to say a thank you
to the people who have provided one of
the most ultimate
treats for the year of 2020 and that is
the ridge wallet if you guys have been
watching the channel for a while you'll
know that we both
really do love our ridge wallets it's
one of the few product placement
opportunities we've ever had where i
actually talk about these dang things
outside of filming a video very grateful
for them rfid blocking sleek
minimal design aluminum titanium carbon
fiber thirty thousand five star reviews
free shipping and returns worldwide and
then for the ultimate treat this
year if you use promo code reject nation
you could save 10
on your order perfect time for this
holiday season i might add just go to
rich.com
reject nation and as much as i'm doing
this voice i sincerely mean it these are
amazing wallets
one of the few things new rockstars and
i have in common
[Music]
oh no yeah i forgot to mention this is
going to be random horror reaction
compilation number nine actually five
nights at freddy's outlast
scp and more what are you gonna do to me
what are you gonna do to me when you
find me
[Music]
[Music]
oh it's vr
[Music]
that sounded like homers
[Music]
sexuality
okay
ew
oh
a piece of paper and you tell me to die
isn't that a little extreme here
[Music]
hmm
oh god what the [ __ ]
he's gonna kill me oh my god
is freudic
[Music]
just ran right into that
i need to get my revenge for poisoning
myself by grabbing onto the duke of them
sitting down
[Music]
dude
[Music]
is awesome
[Music]
[Music]
oh
um
[Music]
he needs subscribers markiplier
so hysterical so hysterical i don't know
what to add to that
markipliers is so damn funny he's just
such an
all-around wonderful youtube talent that
highest
markiplier video is something that i
still occasionally maybe like once a
month will just randomly put on my phone
and just start playing because it's so
incredibly creative
and then he can be just this deep
philosophical guy but then when it comes
to the let's plays
he is easily the one i enjoy watching
the most
he's so funny like when he is just so
involved
so pulled in especially with horror he's
my favorite guy to watch
he's just doing his thing he's just not
thinking and he just lets out whatever
comes out of his subconscious it's just
some of the funniest things in the world
i i
i i i envy him so much yeah i just want
to be him
yeah seriously because too he has this
like overwhelming
energy that doesn't feel fake to me
which is a pretty impressive thing
especially when you do do this
for so much time as he has and i mean
watching him grow over the years from
the five nights at freddy's videos and
then seeing the other stuff mixed in
here i also just love
how much stuff there is in these games
that
almost feels like a glitch or like some
kind of
surreal like so many characters come up
and like
stand and look at you and i appreciated
the uh
the breath of moments they chose because
of course they chose the ones where he's
jumping and freaking out but also those
prolonged weird moments also illustrates
just the magic of
the experience of watching markiplier
yeah you know why i know he's such a
great talent i mean we all know this
right we're doing reactions
every chant every reaction channel
eventually gets this comment
right make your video bigger make your
trailer or whatever your video you're
watching louder and then someone usually
comes to that negative comment and says
like
if you want to watch the actual video
just go watch the actual video
we're here for the reaction right here's
what kept happening to me when i was
watching this one alone
i was only watching markiplier that i
would have to remind myself like he's in
this tiny little box on the screen
and i would have to remind myself like
oh yeah
i need to know what he's also reacting
to right now but i was so
into whatever he was doing that i wasn't
even caring about the video
that he was that he was playing so yeah
uh kudos to him man he's an amazing
talent all right guys that's our cue
with that sound outside if you haven't
subscribed to markiplier do yourself a
favor do that thank you again ridgewalla
for sponsoring this video
video complete we interrupt this
broadcast to shout out some patronage or
pledge to our deleted take some
behind-the-scenes tier
they get a name call out let's do this
j-man reactions
fox cj thomas peter pacheco
rosso baity gpk joanna
st louis matthew mensing gilberto
stephen mendoza michael o'hagan calvin
workman
joshua ruiz buddy rott
rogue
sj94 andrew barber
lucas romero renar k
justin martin kayla waters
kenny quaters rosy baby darth yoda order
66
ruby dynamite becky underwood
anya philip j
smith jr jan smith
jaden brijana davidson
javier gomez melanie leblanc
iron tester brittany bailey
natalie doran irwin roger
marcus werderman chase gardner
gregory bullock tiana h
eva drastic over kent mcnuit
elbay dubstep gorpow
clinton redmond kayla madrid
sean allen bailey reichert thank you
guys so much for pledging at that tier
for patreon hopefully you've been
enjoying it at our patreon love you guys
you guys are some awesome patronage much
love to you
trix treats i want to tickle you all
changed our clothes
yeah just for you just for you guys did
not shoot this in advance
fresh out the laundry let's do it right
now all right we'll see you guys